have you heard Gemini is the most
capable and general model Google has
ever built it's inspired by the way
humans understand the world Gemini 1.0
is built for multimodality meaning it
can recognize and understand text images
audio code and more at the same time so
it better understands nuanced
information and can answer questions
relating to complicated topics that are
hard to put into words and require a
picture or video to explain for example
you can input multiple images such as
your living room and the plants you're
considering buying and ask questions
like which plant would look good in this
living room you can even input an entire
video and ask the model questions about
it vertex AI is the best way for
developers to use the full power of
Gemini with intuitive tooling fully
managed infrastructure and built-in
privacy and safety features vertex AI
allows customization of Gemini with full
data control and benefits from
additional Google Cloud features for
Enterprise security safety privacy and
data governance and compliance